the internet maybe replete with cats
making silly faces but when it comes to
shelter caps being adopted those faces
might not help their chances in 2013
researchers found that humans were more
likely to adopt shelter dogs that
frequently raise their brows possibly
because it makes their faces look more
populous and friendly that led them to
wonder whether potential cat adopters
pay attention to the cat's facial
expressions to figure this out
researchers created cat facts or cat
facial action coding system they
meticulously catalogue every possible
muscle contraction tab space make and
identified 15 different facial movements
7 ear movements and 6 movements
involving the tongue lips nose eyelids
or pupil
the researchers videotaped cats as three
shelters to see how they responded to an
approaching human they recorded two
facial expressions and body movements
from a hundred and sixty s in all and
then followed how long it took each cat
to be adopted surprisingly the cast's
facial expressions didn't seem to affect
how quickly they were adopted what did
make a difference
rubbing has to rub their heads and
bodies on toys and objects were adopted
30 percent more quickly and cats that
didn't the scientists think that the
tongue dogs were domesticated much
earlier than cats and lived in close
quarters with people their facial
expressions had more time and more under
more evolutionary pressure it becomes
friendlier tot whereas in cats
we seem to rely more on overt signals
like nuzzling to decide whether they've
makes good money
[Music]
[Music]